[Music]
three two one action
hey guys welcome back to off-the-record
where we talk about whatever we want and
today we have Anthony here with us he is
a dancer / choreographer because of the
two separate things separate a
co-founder of the kynges and that's the
dance crew that got that's one of ours
to be fair its first run it up yeah I'm
so proud of you too first loser
whatever well you know what it was ty
because we've never been on TV so we're
legit hating oh that's legit like ya
know your job is way better fake hate
it's like a waste I'm sorry
welcome back I didn't lose them I'm
sorry I forgot to mention in a long time
JK news friend we've known that we've
known you since when 2012 2011 2011
really 2011 to kick tour Australia after
we met that was a duck tour I met you
when you were fat but that you weren't
fat than anyway what he was fat exactly
jumba shoot a music video shoot in a
trailer you were dancing in a container
and I was like wow that guy's fat I
didn't go there th this is when people
are using PA he was husky he was like
wow it was the pH fat he doesn't look
like that anymore
how'd you lose it Anthony you just
danced it all off stress oh I'm sorry
look like David actually really like
which version of David yeah Fat David a
skinny David like Miss Kitty David still
kind of fat
look like you need a key Preston Davis I
love you now and you're so I love you
now cuz you're skinny I appreciate it
lose weight you get more friends that's
true Joseph video only recognizes people
that are like nines and tens yeah when
did I see that it's true but what did I
say that like on a video or like 50
videos yeah yeah you were saying your
fantasies are also to go into a like a
swingers club but only if there's super
[ __ ] hot models yeah no nines oh no
nice sorry Oh give me just 10 on a scale
of 20 I'll take it
so you've been traveling a lot I have
traveling is always good but I'm
actually home for a couple weeks and
then I leave for like three and a half
months to China and be stuck in China
why would you want to go to such a place
what part of China I think every time
you bring that up you say he owns
multiple businesses out there why he's
killing it a mogul out there I just want
you to get in trouble by the Chinese
government that's why please just
remember though what's your position on
the China Hong Kong theme yes tell us
what do you think about the 2020
election watch this video goes out and
he's in [ __ ] China and he gets
arrested and assassinated because of us
okay are there for you this is to me I
know I'm sorry you're putting opinions
in use it's not did it for him to me
when you go like that you [ __ ] the world
yeah [ __ ] but like the two cancel out
fine here thank you they've all you've
been doing out they've been killing it
honestly I have a really really you know
be humble I'm getting a really unique
opportunity to work on a big theatre
show out there Oh shame
with the Shin yen ilet's marketing
campaign everywhere yeah I've never seen
the show but I feel like I know it like
it's a part of my life not just la you
know that I see the Toronto Sacramento
it's like Bilby where whatever their
marketing director is I really want to
just sit down talk to them and just like
understand yeah like they are a
worldwide phenomenon no it's not that
one it's actually for a production
company called Franklin Jeb dome I think
the best way to put it is a circus Olay
he was one of the major creative
directors for cert for many years so
like I would say arguably out of like
the 10 best Cirque shows in existence he
directed like six of them so for example
he brought mystère over to Vegas and
that revolutionized the entire
theatrical scene he did like oh oh all
won he did Celine Dion's residency which
was like the top go see residency of all
time when he left in digit amicably when
he left and did his own production group
he did
Laurette at the Wynn so he's kind of got
like that signature of water and he's in
China now his production company is in
charge of throwing this giant Chinese
theatrical show that's based off of like
the four great beauties of China is like
an ancient story about like the four
great beauties and one of the most
beautiful women of all time her name was
like she should and like she was used by
the good King to go pretty much like be
the Trojan horse of the bad Kings
emperors she's so hot that she was gonna
melt the enemy so he falls in love with
her and like you know takes her Nezzer
concubine for many years and then
there's this whole like but then the
enemy king was gay and then when she
went there he was like you can't faze me
[ __ ] wait is this real be making no
he's making huh but imagine though I'm
just saying imagine if you were like
you're my finest concubine I want you to
go and seduce the enemy Emperor and she
goes over there and he goes uh-uh honey
I'm gay that would be a very drunk yeah
interesting story you need to bring one
of y'all generals and then she goes back
failed
that's a good story
I could imagine change like Terrence you
know changes history you'll make your
own I'm gonna do that so you're gonna be
the creative choreography nope no no no
not at all critic just a choreographer I
get it but I get to work with like the
martial arts choreographer I get to work
with the traditional and dance
choreographer get to work with acrobatic
how about Jackie Chan no I don't get to
work with Jackie Chan on this one would
you because they're like you're like
you're a show-and-tell person right now
for a group of second graders yeah the
title says choreographer I think I'm
just gonna I think all of us are like
what they explained to me though you
know what I love about it is that
everybody's a giant creative team we
have like our roles and responsibilities
and our niche talents and whatnot but I
think another day like this creation
whatever is gonna come above it and I
love the philosophy of how they like
think about creation together it's so
that's cool I mean this is again one of
the production groups is responsible for
the largest-scale live theater shows in
the world you know well part of China
Russia which is like a three hours away
from Shanghai was like seven million
people there Wow
then the South was like I have no idea
very flat land with a couple now who Shh
you have to work with because that
sounds like technically well they're all
different movement like a specialist
right so when you have somebody who's
like the most well-known and traditional
Long Sleeve of female traditional
Chinese dancer like a wizard you know
you know the ones with the really long
so we have like one of the best movies
in China that's coming in and then I get
to for example work with her and like
the musical composer to make sure that
it's not the same thing that China seen
over and over because we're looking at a
modern twist yeah and collaborate with
everybody like the the martial arts
choreographer is his name is Jayden he
was on the team with Jet Li so like he's
worked on a lot of movies
or the jet real the real job imaginary
both legendary the martial artists that
it looks really really old now Jet Li
that one oh you got old really really
bad people get old so how do you
communicate with the Chinese speakers
well obviously in the collaboration room
when we're like just working with the
directors like there's enough
translation where people are just
communicating freely right but when we
actually get into them into the work
space with like a cast and different
things like that it's it's hard to
explain but because it's a movement can
you do it is and then they go oh course
you're sure like a lot of the philosophy
is not about like doing the most
beautiful thing but rather like pulling
the monster in each of us out right so
so a lot of it would be for example like
show me who you are and don't say
anything just show me who you are
oh that's accuracy by putting that like
by putting you against the wall in this
situation right now it's like funny but
then I'm gonna like honestly ask you
realistically show me who you are and
then you're just gonna eventually find
something that's gonna be like deep and
honest to the core that we might be able
to use so I'm constantly looking for
realism in what like the human
experience can bring to the table it is
a really fun and like unique way to kind
of extract artistry that's like
innovative yeah so like that's just an
example of like how we might go about
creating versus me sitting in my room
and trying to choreograph something and
just put it out there and be like
there's some of my work so it's like a
big movement jam session first yeah
until you feel like it's at the core
there's something like electricity in
the air
and then we started like structuring the
bit they're telling me not to like
choreograph full sequences and numbers
because like there needs to be room for
things organically developed that the
music might change an idea might spawn a
whole new ending like so it's like
create chunks and pieces at a time only
to see how things can develop how high
is everyone when they're doing this [ __ ]
on life yeah on by Jove that Evan leaf
life there's a huge opium thing that's
going on no no honestly people are just
in there and it's creates it's it's pure
creation
that's a cool it's like you're
choreographing the chorus and then you
come together to make it to meet the
verses honestly I don't think it's so
objective like anything can happen for
any number
really just depends the chorus could
change anything the only thing that
really matters is just hitting the theme
of the four beauties is that the theme
like there's a one major umbrella theme
and that's like an umbrella story that
everybody in China is familiar with like
that story
it's like Pinocchio you tell it right
it's like a Zen buddy seem like the show
Hamilton nah okay so there I also
haven't seen it but like what made it so
popular people are like really attracted
to is that there's such a modern twist
right on how exactly so they're using a
modern form of communication if you will
that is relevant to current culture to
express the historical you know
happenings that was on back there so we
want to also do a similar thing and I'm
not gonna give too much away but what we
want to figure out how to take a
traditional story and make it relevant
and exciting to watch for anybody in age
demographic right after type I mean the
venue alone is like like 75 million
dollars oh my god yeah they should have
a clown riding a tricycle and he rides
it into the middle and he's like oh no
where is everyone
and then he has an umbrella and then he
rides away that represents living in a
communist regime yeah I'll just thrown
it out there you can write that one down
eventually written okay I feel like I
already happened in the Cirque show it
sounds like oh it doesn't make any sense
that's so cool I I [ __ ] love live
shows I think that's the best form of
entertainment I enjoy like sitting
through and I can actually sit through
without [ __ ] being all fidgety and
[ __ ] and it's weird how just movement in
general can bring out a lot of different
feelings within the audience yeah and
there's no dialogue something a lot of
the times there's just not nothing just
just people moving and it's like damn
just this lady's [ __ ] on a trapeze
[ __ ] throwing herself around and
[ __ ] why do I feel so soft and good
inside well I mean right what is it
in terms of communication they say like
body language is what like fifty five
percent or something like that maybe
intonation and pitch is like thirty
percent
I think words itself actual words is
like a complex seven percent mm-hmm in
terms of like a hundred percent of
communication so much can be translated
by just body language
just like that that attitude that
feeling yeah and one of the things that
keep saying and like the philosophy and
the culture of this you know the actual
production to is that like how you feel
when you create it is how people will
feel when you play it so if you think
it's money money money money money then
people are gonna be sitting down going
money money money money might be
something shallow about it you know of
course everything's like subjective in
terms of how people receive things
everybody's different but like how we
feel when we're creating our excitement
the love or the stress that we pour into
it is gonna be the same type of ride
that an audience should feel is there
like a certain headspace you try to get
into before you create anything then I
think first and foremost for me I think
I have to throw everything I know away
because it's not the point is to like
bring my skill set to the table which at
that if I think about what I know and
understand it's like a utility utility
belt I want to wear it and I want to
have it in that space so I can use it
but I don't want to be like this is my
entire understanding it's just the tools
like everything else should be like
discovered and like for example one of
the things that like usually happens I
guess during these productions they say
that this creative amazing creative
director Franco he like comes in in the
last like two weeks and he like just
flips everything that you have upside
down regardless of where this shows that
because there's a belief that like a
sense of urgency right and like human
beings when their backs are against the
wall that's when something truly magical
comes out so no matter how prepared or
how much we think we know about the show
or how finalized we believe it is this
guy's gonna come in and no matter what
it's gonna figure out something has just
turned everything upside down
he already gives me PTSD man yeah as
soon as you're walking like the right
and they say they say it's the most
stressful and most wonderful experience
I agree though what a great cult leader
I like I'm inspired and we haven't even
gotten to it you know that that lower
the production yet I'm scared but like I
think that I agree that like for example
think someone's gonna die I really hope
cuz like Cirque shows people die what
are you talking abou though yeah they
knew I mean
everyone dies every day but no people no
not every day in a search so what about
to say what he's excited to hurry go go
go that's exciting - there are freak
accidents that happen you know but I
don't even know what my chain of thought
is I know what's exciting you're gonna
really forgot because that is a pretty
huge topic okay so you were saying how
he's basically gonna put you under some
heavy pressure and you're like oh [ __ ]
I'm nervous but I'm excited I'm gonna
pull the best out of you into the sense
of like for example even with like the
kynges when we create stuff we have like
a month to create something sometimes I
like screws us over like trying so hard
oh yeah yeah yeah well we're on like TV
shows where you have like three days
till I figure out something you have to
clear a song it's a dinner costume do
you have to figure out your posse and
you don't sleep at all yeah it's the
most painful we lose weight we're
stressed out we always feel like this
high level stress we don't see the
product but yet for some reason that's
always our most impactful or unique
artistry because like the how we felt
when we created tapping into the primal
so a lot of people do this in order for
you to change yourself psychologically
like it starts with the biology a lot so
they do sleep deprivation fasting all
sorts of things like that to tap your
mind into a primal state of survival and
that usually has a very raw human
emotion that is pure and a lot of people
try to achieve that but it helps you
reset your mind state because we get to
meta in our head we get to [ __ ] like
everything is rules everything is this
everything is whatever and then my left
brain your two left
yeah and in order to break out of that
mindset this is a great way to kind of
tap into that so he's putting stress in
a safe way like it's like that and in
that that pressure will just make you go
oh [ __ ] because when you know when you
overthink art it's no longer art yeah
you're just constructing something yeah
and you get all the theory in but then
like yeah exactly you have to like find
this flow state and I think that Zen
flow state where you're purely creating
is not easy to get but it's something
that everybody's always trying to be in
and actually creating something so we're
just forcefully finding it in an
aggressive
in stressful way but I also believe
that's why I like their productions are
that's why the best ideas come when
you're taking a [ __ ] honestly when I'm
choreographing it on block I'll go take
a piss and and usually that's when an
idea will come back to me it's really
weird it's like uh-huh your flow state I
have a new way of pissing actually you
sit down I don't know I do get I do get
ideas right I do get ideas when I'm
pissing so now I don't know why but now
because I do get these I break yeah at
least you're singing the toilet
now when I piss I piss like a
three-year-old so I pull my pants all
the way down to my ankles so I don't
have to pee on my pants and I'm on my
phone I write my ideas and I'm pissing
even in public yeah like when I'm like
if I have the idea why did you make that
why did you breeze I don't like it some
like crazy [ __ ] revolutionary most of
us pull our dick door flies and we
pissed through there
and as an adult like I'm like we asked
you the best way to pee is us when
you're a child because not both had an
operation I don't touch my dick do you
do the lift the shirt sometimes I do
know it's just like once I start peeing
it just goes right in the Misun right
it's all a sudden out of nowhere like
I'm fine of everything's chill and then
all of a sudden I have to pee now like
right now so a lot of times I just take
whatever I'm doing I can't be
interrupted right now I hate that when
you're like in the when you're in the
flow state diaper you're so in the zone
right now yeah yeah sometimes I'm in the
middle like washing dishes or cooking
I'm like
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]